Jordan is on the line in North Carolina
hi Jordan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
Anthony and I help hey Dave how are you
doing great man what's up so my wife and
I were on baby step number two and we
bought a home about a year ago and we
the HVAC system on it is about 15 years
old so it's older than dirt and it's on
the fritz and the maintenance company
that I've had come clean it up
recommended about a thousand dollars
worth of work to be done on it so I know
it needs a lot of work and it's 15 years
old so I don't want to I'm having to
spend that much money on it and we've
also got old gutters that aren't working
properly so since well baby stepped over
to I'm wondering we're budgeting for
these fixes fits in only if they're an
emergency well the good if you were to
believe the people that looked at an
HVAC system they would say it is an
emergency there's they just say there's
things getting into the system that you
know it's not good to be breathing in
and then also the gutters something yet
would have a gutter guy tell you it's an
emergency too because they don't
function it also we're getting water all
around the foundation you can see it's
spilling over eight on the range but
Jordan you know they're gonna tell you
that right just to get your business I
mean right here it is it still working
oh yeah okay so it's better to working
but HVAC systems working so clean the
gutters out and get them and buy some
black plaster clean but okay I mean just
redirect them you can do it yeah yeah
I'll get you some plastic right there
are those the house so they're they're
as old as the house so they're not
they're designed differently than they
are currently then what you would get
for gutters now so they sag and you
can't really do anything about them
others so you bought a money pit baby
I mean well gutters aren't too expensive
but I mean I'm definitely comfortable
waiting but I didn't notice
maybe I should budget because so how
much dirt have you got about 18,000 and
what's your household income about
110,000 and so how fast are you going to
pay off 18,000 definitely within the
year
we just refinance and so came into some
money to pay off some of the loans this
month so still try to figure out the
budget definitely within the year
hopefully quicker hopefully like six
months yeah I would think six months
yeah okay these things don't make it six
months that's true
yeah okay here's the thing okay at the
end of the story
you've got your debt at the end of story
either way you're debt-free and you have
got new gutters a new eating and air
system that you pay cash for right
that's the end of the story when when
both of these things are accomplished
the exercise here is what's more
important than the actual decision okay
and the exercise is I've got to learn to
control these purchase decisions and
make them fit to my goals rather than to
the heating and air company's goals and
so I'm not saying you don't need gutters
or don't need a heating and air system
but but there's something happens when
you say I'm gonna force myself to wait
and knock this dead out and then I'm
gonna do this stuff because that's the
right order to do it now again if your
family is is cold in the winter you've
got to have a heater okay that's not
what I'm saying
but you know once I decided I was
getting out of debt everything was on
hold until then and there's something
that there's a good thing that happens
in you and your wife's character and in
how you're approaching this when you say
I'm just not fixing crap right now I'm
not gonna find any reason to spend any
money unless I have to to survive and so
if I'm you I'm putting these things on
hold for six months I'm gonna tack this
18 thousand with a vengeance knock it
out tighten this budget up tighten it
tighten it tighten and tighten it and
then as quickly as I can I'm gonna do
those gutters cuz they're gonna be the
cheaper of the two and then I'm gonna
have that heating and air right behind
it and I might even do those things
before I did my emergency fund even but
I'm gonna I'm gonna make myself have the
discipline to not go the normal route
because the normal route is what keeps
people screwed their whole lives yeah
you're right Davey you know what Davey
said something key their discipline so
discipline is the bridge between where
you are and where you want to go you
want to be debt-free so you gotta have
discipline today and say you know what
hey this is where I'm at I want to be
debt-free I'm not gonna do this I'm
gonna go ahead and take care of the
priorities which is get out of debt and
then I'll tag that I met a young lady
just the other day Dave she said hey I
was living in my apartment for six
months with no no couch no bed I was
sleeping on the floor because I wanted
to become debt-free yeah I'm like now
that's determination and that's
discipline but you know and and
everybody looks at that so that's where
but here's what's happening is you're
saying I'm gonna live like no one else
so later I can live and give like no one
else yes sir because you could always
find something to do
these are both valid expenditures he's
got absolutely it's valid to fix these
gutters it's valid to do the heating and
air and yeah you're right the the
vendors will tell you you're gonna die
if you have black mold if you don't fix
these two things immediately you know
you're a bad parent to your children or
whatever all this kind of crap but it's
just not that